-It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hash tags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hash tags ♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
So, since movie theaters
are open once again,
I sent out the
#addawordruinamovie.
-Hmm.
-And I asked you guys to add one
word to the title
of a famous movie
and just
make it way worse.
Within minutes, it was a number
one trending topic.
That's nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Number one trending
topic across the country.
Thank you.
Thank you for playing along.
So now, I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
responses from you guys.
This first one here
is from @iamcindychu.
She says "The Devil Wears
Knockoff Prada."
Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
No one knows the difference.
-Yeah, they can't tell.
-No one knows the difference.
This one's from @kansasbradbury.
-Ooh.
-He says "Zoom Interview
with the Vampire."
Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A little less scary telling
a vampire he's on mute.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @ZHansard85.
He says "G.I. Joe Pesci."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Do I amuse you,
Cobra commander?"
[ Laughter ]
"I make you laugh?
Get your shine box."
[ Laughter ]
Get your shine box.
-With the Cobra Commander.
-You ever heard Joe Pesci sing,
by the way?
-He's a great singer.
-He can really sing,
like phenomenal.
He used to be, yeah.
He's fantastic.
I didn't know that.
I Was like --
-Crooning.
-Yeah, I was listening
like seriously Sinatra
or something.
I was like, "This is awesome."
I Shazamed it.
I Shazamed Sinatra.
-Oh, wow, wow.
Shazamed Sinatra.
-Four times.
-[Indistinct]
-Yeah.
-Yeah, Joe Pesci.
Dude's unbelievable.
Anyway.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Trivia. Just some quick trivia.
That's all.
-Go fish.
-Yeah.
-This one's from @najaawhatnow.
-Huh?
-She says
"Call Me By Your mom's Name."
Oh, hey.
-Oh.
-Hey. Hey.
Get it.
Go to bed.
-Mama.
This one's from @FaceTimePolice.
-Oh.
-They say "Children of the Corn
Chowder."
[ Laughter ]
That's sounds equally
frightening.
Yeah.
-Very frightening.
-This is from @tamika.
She says "Batman Begins
Scrapbooking."
[ Laughter ]
"Joker, this is yeah."
-"Wayne industries opened up."
-"My friend made this pottery."
[ Laughter ]
"I think you put flowers
in it, whatever.
You can drink out of it,
I guess."
-"I'm going to glue some gold
cord to the edge of this page,
to really highlight
the pictures of Robin."
-"What I do is I stamp
the glitter glue."
[ Laughter ]
"I get some --"
"I just make a whole page
with glitter glue
and when it dries,
I glue pictures on top of that.
Just makes for a
decent background."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from
@KryptonianCodex.
-Ooh.
-He says "The Davinci Bro Code."
[ Laughter ]
-Dude. Dude.
-This one's from @yosemitesam17.
-Whoa.
-He says "Butter Knives Out."
Oh, that's --
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @ReneeJordan78.
She says "It's A Wonderful
Life Magazine."
[ Laughter ]
-That's a great movie.
-I may cry.
-"Ah, what is this?"
Styrofoam.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, it's the moon landing."
-"They were kissing a woman."
[ Laughter ]
-[Indistinct] in jail.
"Advertisement for Jell-O."
[ Laughter ]
-These are all things that we're
in "Life" magazine.
-That's correct.
-The actual "Life" magazine.
Ask your grandparents.
-This one's from @bigmanu.
They say
"Justice Softball League."
Oh, I'd watch that.
[ Laughter ]
This last one is from @aitcheh.
He says "James and the Giant
Peach Emoji."
There you have it, everybody.
Those are "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.